I love reading inspirational quotes in
Gandhi's quote really stuck with me be
the change you want to see in the world
my friends we all want the gold but we
don't love the grind what's up with that
so many people go after mentors just
because they're successful at something
they need to be successful at what you
are wanting to do when my mental
bandwidth is the highest that's when I
go into action but first thing in the
morning the first hour is me producing
my best content period I'm the host of a
fire and award-winning podcaster I
interviewed today's most inspiring and
successful entrepreneurs seven days a
week in four years I've interviewed over
1,600 entrepreneurs amassed over 40
million listens and have turned ego fire
into a multi-million dollar a year
business I've created two journals to
help guide entrepreneurs to success the
freedom journal and the mastery journal
I'm John Lee Dumas and here are my top
ten rules for success
[Music]
five years ago almost to the day is when
I first heard about podcasting for the
same reason because I was sick and tired
of Miley Cyrus on the radio I even went
to the sports radio but I'm not a Padres
or Chargers fan so I go wasn't loving
the sports talk radio either these
commercials were so long so I found
podcasting as a listener and I fell in
love with the medium I got it right away
on demand targeted content you could
listen to it and you could really
connect with people and I started
listening to people like Pat Flynn who
he's now become my good friends he's
right here in San Diego Andrew Warner
David Siteman Garland these guys
inspired me and I said man I don't have
to follow this traditional route that I
thought I had to coming from a very
traditional family military etc and my
eyes were opened and it still was a
couple years before I made that leap but
in September of 2012 that was the date I
launched entrepreneur fire mhm here we
are just one thousand episodes later now
which is crazy the thing is yeah seven
days a week and we average over 1
million unique listens per month in over
145 countries so it's really become a
platform that reaches the worlds which I
love so when you think of just like
almost becoming a lawyer
and being in some of those just moments
like what was it that bubbled over we
said you know I just can't take it
anymore where you're just like you know
I have to just do something different
because you know last time we had a lot
of folks that have quit their jobs
you know replaced income and so if
you're in that you know II quadrant that
we talked about on the cash flow
quadrant so what was it that just said
you know I can't take it anymore yeah
I'm just going to go for it for me what
was the really big boil over point as I
was in commercial real estate and I did
enjoy a lot of the profession but the
reality was this I locked down a huge
deal and it was going to be a big
Commission check and I was not excited
about it I was like man I am NOT excited
about locking down what's going to turn
out to be you know a five figure check
because I'm like now I got to write the
contract up I got to do this I got to do
that and I'm sure a lot of people in
this room can resonate with either your
current or past jobs just not being
excited about what it's going to take to
get to do what you need to do
and I said if I'm not even excited about
bringing in this big Commission like
then this is as good as it gets like is
this the rest of my life is this what
the rest of my life is going to be like
where I'm just like looking at the watch
you know trying to make a beeline home
as soon as possible walking down big
deals not even caring is that going to
be my life and I said that's it this I
refuse to live a life on those terms I'm
going to take control it had always been
in the back of my mind I'm loving
listening to these interviews with
inspiring entrepreneurs Pat Flynn's
podcast was twice a month David Siteman
Garland once a week Andrew Warner once a
week and they were bringing on great
guests and telling great stories and I
was listening to these interviews as I
was driving to work being like man I
need more of these because I'm driving
to work five days a week hit in the gym
I need more and I couldn't find it and
so the idea was in the back of my mind
like I love reading inspirational quotes
in Gandhi's quote really stuck with me
be the change you want to see in the
world I wanted to see a seven day a week
podcast I didn't know if anybody else
wanted to see that but I decided to stop
just whining and complaining about the
fact that it didn't exist in step
forward and make it exist my friends we
all want the gold but we don't love the
grind what's up with that
I get it we see entrepreneurs that we
admire having these amazing experiences
around the world we see that Olympian
with tears streaming down their face as
the Stars and Stripes go up and the
star-spangled banner is playing but my
friends that's just a snapshot of the
success of their lives you don't see
that 10 years of failure that
entrepreneur went through to get to
success you don't see those 4 years of
sweat that olympian had to put in to get
that gold medal no we just want that
gold medal we don't even think about the
grind that it took to stand on that
podium it's time for a mindset shift
fire nation I've interviewed over 1400
successful entrepreneurs and they all
love the grind you must love the grind
so set a goal make it big make it
meaningful and then start the grind
start it today the smartest thing that I
really should say that I did and my
biggest early success was making that
realization that I needed a mentor
because again I only knew how to press
play on a podcast nothing else so I
looked out there to the podcasters that
were currently at where I wanted to be I
think that's so critical so many people
go after mentors just because they're
successful at something they need to be
successful at what you are wanting to do
they need to be where you want to be and
for 3 months in a heavy investment on my
part rightfully so I was mentored by
Jamie and that's just what opened up so
many doors so quickly ok now we had a
great question from Facebook which was
if someone is starting right now and
they can't afford that kind of
investment to find a mentor or coach you
know what do you suggest that they do
because I mean at the very beginning it
seems like you have no doors and no
connections and you know you're just
like yourself alone starting a podcast
in your basement
yeah what do you suggest to them so
number one I would say getting that
one-on-one mentor is critical so if you
know you can't afford X like think about
what you actually can afford what can
you invest what dollar amount and then
just go for me a great example I people
that come to
being out all the time say John like can
you mentor me to be a podcaster and I
don't even have like a price anymore
I don't want to want mentoring right
just I focus on other parts of my
business but I'm able to say you know
listen I'm sorry I don't mentor but I
have a couple great options for you
what's your price range let me introduce
you and hand you off to an amazing
mentor who loves doing this who's great
at what he does or what she does and
then you'll be off to the races so
fortune favors the bold
so still reach out with that mentality
and then also offer like what kind of
value are you going to exchange you're
maybe you're willing you know to run
their Twitter account and maybe you're
willing to to create some images have
some design for them think about the
bartering that you can do trading your
time which is valuable saving they're
saving them time right there can be some
really cool things that you can exchange
that doesn't have to necessarily be
dollars and cents and then also I do
want to add there's also some great
group group coaching out there that's a
lot cheaper and then somebody that
you've interviewed as well Louis house
as well as myself
we run membership masterminds he runs a
school of greatness
I run Fire Nation elite these are a
membership masterminds that are around a
hundred people each and so it's a lot
less expensive whenever people reach out
to me and say you know I'm doubting what
I'm doing I say well congratulations
you're a human being that's what it
means to be a human I've I've you doubt
what you do is that voice inside our
head you know it's innate in all of us
we're born with the impostor syndrome so
you know we don't walk outside of the
cave at dark with the saber-tooth Tigers
like there's a voice saying don't walk
outside it's dangerous but we don't live
in that same world anymore but we still
have that inside our head and that's
fine but we need to learn not to let it
control our lives but to embrace that
fear and so I still have it every single
day I mean we talked about my revenue
last month you know I still wake up and
say man like you know should I be doing
it like like should I do this webinar
like is that you know I have these
doubts in these fears and that's just a
reality and I've just learned to embrace
that this quote is by the ex-president
Theodore Roosevelt you delivered this in
Paris back in 1910 it is not the critic
who counts
not the man who points out how the
strong man stumbles or where the doer of
Deeds could have done better credit
belongs to the man who is actually in
the arena whose face is marred by blood
by dirt by sweat who strives valiantly
who airs who comes up short again and
again because there is no effort without
error and shortcoming but who does
actually strive to do the deeds knows
great enthusiasms and great devotions
and spends himself on a worthy cause Who
at the best in the end knows high
achievement and at the worst if he fails
he fails daring greatly so that his
place will never be with those cold and
timid souls who know neither victory nor
defeat
I had this mentor Jaime and I was in
cliff ravenscraft broadcast mastermind
and they said John you're insane it's
going to be so much work don't do a
seven-day-a-week podcast do a one day a
week mod cast and I think this is really
important to is that you need as an
entrepreneur to really take the great
feedback and the great advice from those
who have come before you from those who
are mentoring you but at the same time
you need to listen to your gut to your
intuition I took so many great pieces of
advice from both cliff and Jamie and
apply it to my business but when it came
to a seven-day-a-week podcast my
intuition my gut was telling me it had
to be that way like that's what I that's
what I was meant to create I had the
military discipline I knew how to do you
know create systems and I knew how to
work hard I had the finances to allow me
to do so for a significant amount of
time without being distracted by other
things I knew that I couldn't make it
happen I knew that was going to be my
USP that unique selling price ish and my
differentiator so I listened to my heart
I listened to my god and I think that's
so important for people to realize that
you're going to have something in your
gut that's telling you to do something
and hopefully it's something that
is unique and it is different and make
sure you follow that we have a lot of
people that are gonna watch this that
are watching that start podcast or have
podcast or want to start them so what's
kind of the the the right way to do it
for you if you are willing to step back
and say hey I am going to commit to
delivering free valuable inconsistent
content those three things I'm going to
commit to delivering free valuable
inconsistent content you are going to
grow an audience in your niche but if
you can commit to getting to that
tipping point and that tipping point is
going to happen when you're doing the
free buy with inconsistent content you
will get to revenue but it's not going
to come overnight over one month it's
going to take time that's why I'm not
against a side hustle I want to talk for
just a minute about action versus
reaction such a critical concept so many
people start their day in reaction mode
let me grab my phone let me see what's
on X let's see what's on Y let's see
what's on Z Facebook what's in my email
what do people want from me you start a
reaction mode you're likely going to end
in reaction mode no bueno we don't want
to start or end in reaction mode how
about this we're going to start an
action mode we're going to take actions
that improve our business add value to
what we're bringing in value to other's
lives when my mental bandwidth is the
highest that's when I go into action but
first thing in the morning the first
hour is me producing my best content
period I'm going to spend my best mental
bandwidth answering somebody's email so
most questions someone asked want/need
know it's your best mental bandwidth
reactions part of the game though
realize you do need to engage you do
need to answer those emails those tweets
those Facebook messages you snapchat me
I'm answering back that is part of the
game start to be intentional about when
you act and when you react and remember
use your best mental bandwidth your
energy for action Fire Nation is
entrepreneurs we love getting right to
the finish line and then never crossing
it do you want to know why because as
long as we're living in a pre-launch
mode we're living in a fairy world of
this might work it might work but as
soon as you press publish then it gets
real
then the
market tells you if this is going to
work or not you either win or you lose
and we are terrified of losing we want
to live in that comfortable pre-launch
stage where everything and anything is
possible fire nation everybody told me
yo fire would not work that a daily
podcast was doomed to fail so I kept
pushing back my launch like living my
fairy world of this Mike I wanted my
dream to stay alive a little longer
until I pushed that go button that
publish button yo fire was still
possibly a success reality hadn't set in
oh yes your chances of losing are a lot
less pre-launch but your chances of
winning are zero so take this away Fire
Nation you will lose if you remain in
your fairytale lands of pre launch and
you will never win there's one way to
win press launch let the market decide
alarm clock would go off very early
every single morning I'd wake up I check
my phone immediately for any emails that
had come in and then it'd be shower
shave dress in my full suit and jump in
a car and that car to me represented my
first kind of drudgery task for the day
it made me feel trapped because I'd done
all the right things I hadn't gone to
college I had been an officer in the
Army for eight years I've gone to
corporate finance I'd worked with John
Hancock I'd done commercial real estate
I had done all the right things and now
here I was stuck on this hamster wheel
going nowhere inspiring nobody
especially not myself and just feeling
like I was trapped in this world that I
had created and it was a sinking pit in
my stomach and
I just was wondering why why have I not
found what I'm looking for when I've
done everything that I was told I was
supposed to do Here I am years later on
the same hamster wheel feeling like I've
even further behind where I thought I
was five years ago and this sinking
mundane feeling would just not go away
it was ever-present with me and I just
wanted freedom
and I just wanted freedom I just wanted
to do work that I was inspired by and I
just want to do worth and inspired
others
[Music]
you
so there I was stuck in traffic
again but at least I had my podcast or
so I thought
then before I knew it who my last
podcast had ended and I scrolled through
my iPod and there was nothing left and I
thought to myself man I have to sit here
for another 45 minutes in traffic with
nothing but the radio I was devastated
but at that moment at that devastation
moment that is truly when my aha moment
happened that's when the light bulb went
off I said what there's not a
seven-day-a-week
podcast there should be a podcast that
comes out every single day of the week
that interviews inspiring and successful
entrepreneurs and that's when I have my
lightbulb moment I said there should be
someone that creates it why not me I
know all these great entrepreneurs who
are a host of their own shows I could be
just like them I can do this
so I had all of these thoughts swirling
in my head am I going to fail am I gonna
look like a fool in front of my friends
and family who up to this point and only
see me as a success and these were real
fears I used to wake up sweating in the
middle of the night saying what am i
doing this is insane and the only way
that I'd be able to go back to sleep was
by convincing myself the one I woke up
in the morning I was going to give it
all up and go crawling back to my job in
commercial real estate but luckily for
me I would wake up in the morning but
someone be shining and I say you know
what I'm gonna give it one
day one more day I'm going to sit down
I'm going to learn what it takes to
upload a media file I'm going to learn
how to create great audio on the Lord it
takes to be an interview or a host of a
show in every single day I would get
shot down I would struggle I would come
up against another wall that would knock
me down but I kept getting up I kept
taking one step forward for every half
step that I was taking back and slowly
but surely I saw myself turning into a
podcaster right before my very own eyes
and it was a slow process but it did
come and I was able to continue to move
forward until the watch entrepreneur on
fire on September 22nd because at that
point there was no turning back
Fire Nation look what we've created look
at the inspiration we spread throughout
this world a podcast seven days a week
interviewing the most inspiring and
successful entrepreneurs in the world
Seth Godin Guy Kawasaki Tim Ferriss Gary
Vaynerchuk we are listening to in over
145 countries millions and millions of
unique
Fire Nation look at what we've created
look at what we've done and we've just
started
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Ethan Parisot
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know what did John say that really
resonated with you what lessons are you
going to take and apply it to your life
or to your business leave it in the
comments and I'm going to join in the
discussion thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon